well many people have struggled in this
pandemic and for some that's meant an
addiction to drugs
drug overdose deaths reached an all-time
high in 2020.
madison kimbrough went to a facility
today that specializes in addressing
trauma
as well as loss and she joins us live in
the newsroom with that story madison
yeah i spoke to two therapists who say
this is the busiest they've ever been
and while many are feeling a little bit
of normalcy now that the vaccine is
available there's still
so much uncertainty and stress making it
very hard for the majority of people to
cope
any pretty much any substance that you
can use to distract
or try to not feel something that's what
people are turning to to numb away from
these things
owner and therapist sam richardson of
las vegas therapy
says since opening its doors three years
ago new clients are coming in
every day we've definitely seen an
uptick in mental health problems
according to the cdc drug overdose
deaths rose by close to 30 percent in
the united states in 2020
hitting the highest number ever recorded
and here in nevada the department of
health and human services
reports that accidental drug overdose
deaths in nevada
increased 37 percent from the first half
of 2019 to the first half of 2020.
majority of the casework that we do are
really focused on trauma
falls drug overdoses and things of that
nature
and then you have the component of
suicide deaths in nevada fentanyl
overdoses nearly tripled in the first
part of 2020
and many people who use these drugs
start out with prescriptions
and then the addiction takes off from
there as for ways to help
reporting any type of behavior that
seems off is vital and surrounding
yourself with people
is key when the stress comes in let's
turn to somebody you don't need to do it
on your own
now crisis support services of nevada is
available to help their number is on
your screen
along with las vegas therapy and several
other specialists across
the valley reporting live in the
newsroom madison kimbrough 8 news now